رجب طيب اردو استلم دفه السلطه منذ عام
2003 اول رئيس منتخب مباشره عام 2014
شهدت فتره حكمه محاوله انقلاب فاشله عام
تمكن حزبه من الفوز باستفتاء عام 2017
وفرض تعديلات دستوريه
تحولت تركيا في عهده من النظام البرلماني
للرئاسي
حكم عقدين ويسعى لولايه رئاسيه ثالثه قدم
وعودا اقتصاديه عده تستهدف الشباب والتضخم
[موسيقى]
سينان يدخل سباق الانتخابات الرئاسيه
للمره الاولى ويعد اصغر مرشح مرشح عن
تحالف الاجداد الذي يضم اربعه احزاب تعرف
بمواقفها القوميه
عضو سابق في حزب الحركه القوميه طرد منها
عام 2017 لكنه ظل مخلصا له
اشتهر بخطابه العنصري ضد اللاجئين من ابرز
وعوده الرئاسيه اعاده المهاجرين الى
بلادهم الغاء نظام الرئاسي العوده للنظام
البرلماني
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات